bonjour à tous dans quelques semaines le
gouvernement rendra ses arbitrages en
matière de politique énergétique
c'est un débat qui s'annonce passionnée
en france et pour éclairer un peu ce
débat j'ai invité jean marc jancovici
bonjour vous êtes consultant expert des
questions énergétiques on va essayer
avec vous de déblayer quelques idées
reçues
avant ces annonces qui seront faites par
le gouvernement la première question qui
se pose parce qu'on en parle beaucoup
c'est celle du climat en quoi le sujet
est il lié à la lutte contre les
émissions de co2 en france on est il
faut le dire je crois à la insisté on
est dans un cas un peu particuliers en
france par rapport au reste du monde
pour ce qui concerne le système
électrique puisque avec le nucléaire on
émet moins de co2 dans les modes de
production électrique qui n'émettent pas
de co2 ou très peu de co2 on va dire
vous avez l'hydroélectricité vous avez
un mac les airs les barrages c'est ça
vous avez le nucléaire et puis vous avez
ce qu'on appelle les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables c'est à dire l'éolien le
solaire la géothermie biogaz etc
il se trouve qu'en france 90% de la
production électrique n'émet pas de co2
c'est à dire c'est du nucléaire et
l'hydroélectricité depuis 30 ans
maintenant
donc nous on a fait en ce qui concerne
le climat l'essentiel du chemin sur la
production électrique depuis 30 ans déjà
et ensuite les particuliers par rapport
au reste du monde c'est à dire que dans
le monde
l'électricité et 2 fait un importante
facteur de démission de sacs de quelques
pays qui nous ressemblent veut avec des
proportions de nucléaire et
d'électricité qui sont variables
la suède par exemple la norvège c'est
que l'hydroélectricité pas nucléaire la
suisse l'essentiel le brésil voilà tous
ces pays ont essentiellement des
barrages et ou du nucléaire par contre
si on regarde dans le monde dans son
ensemble la production électrique est
fait avant tout avec du charbon 40% de
l'électricité mondiale puis du gaz 25%
de l'électricité mondiale ce qui fait de
la production électrique
le premier poste d'émission de gaz à
effet de serre dans toutes les activités
humaines dans le monde d'accord une fois
qu'on a dit ça
d'un point de vue du climat faire
évoluer l'equilibre on va dire entre
nucléaire et énergies renouvelable en
france c'est relativement neutre
c'est alors c'est un débat qui est hors
problèmes climatiques et c'est assez
paradoxal de voir que dans ce pays on a
investi l'essentiel de nos moyens
économiques dans des renouvelables
électriques tout en professant encore il
ya quelques jours où une planète ce
mythe que on s'occupe activement du
climat en fait c'est faux la france ne
s'occupa activement du climat
aujourd'hui elle s'en est occupé
activement il ya 30 ans quand elle a
construit son parc nucléaire et à ce
moment c'est pas ça qu'elle avait en
tête
et depuis trente ans on fait rien de
particulier ont fait rien de mieux que
les autres on va dire le problème chez
nous il est dans l'utilisation du
pétrole et du gaz est un tout petit peu
du charbon c'est à dire la mobilité
essentiellement au pétrole
le chauffage le pétrole et le gaz c'est
4 fois l'énergie électrique dans le
chauffage et l'industrie toi là c'est là
que sont les sujets en ce qui concerne
le co2 et si on prend les gaz or co2 on
a également un sujet avec l'agriculture
qui n'est pas un débat énergétique mais
qui est un débat climatique
revenons à notre système électrique on
s'est fixé comme objectif de réduire à
50% la part du nucléaire dans la
production électrique contre environ 75%
aujourd'hui une première échéance avait
été fixée en 2025 on sait aujourd'hui
qu'elle est totalement et d'indéniables
on parle plutôt de 2035
est ce que ça vous paraît crédible ou
pas alors c'est surtout un objectif qui
de mon point de vue n'a aucun intérêt
qu'ils sont en 2025 2035 2040 5 ou 2082
tout simplement parce que comme je le
dis on a déjà fait le travail sur la
décarbonation du système électrique et
que nos capitaux doivent aller en
priorité nos capitaux et notre temps de
travail entre temps de cerveau
disponible
doivent aller en priorité dans la
décarbonation du reste donc s'occuper
d'abord de baisser la part du nucléaire
à 50% c'est s'occuper d'un problème qui
est un problème secondaire
ça revient quelque part à dire que le
risque nucléaire qui en plus
augmenterait dans ce genre de programme
ce qui est paradoxal est quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus important que le
risque climatique et ça n'est pas ma
vision de la rhk le risque nucléaire
augmenterez c'est totalement contre
intuitif on se dit si on baisse la part
du nucléaire on en baisse le risque
nucléaire parce que tout le monde pense
que si on passe le nucléaire de 75 à 50%
de la production annuelle on va baisser
la puissance nucléaire d'un tiers or
c'est pas ça qui va se passer ce qui va
se passer c'est qu'on va garder la
puissance nucléaire par contre on va
baisser son utilisation annuelle d'un
tiers
donc on va garder parce que c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne et en espagne
en termes de mobilisation des moyens
donc ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va
garder un système qui sera le même qui a
les mêmes coûts parce que le système
nucléaire est un système à coûts fixes
en gros il vous coûte la même chose que
vous en servir beaucoup un peu on va le
garder en garantie parce que à 6 heures
du matin un jour d'hiver il traverse
quand même même s'il n'ya pas de soleil
vous entendez par là pardon c'est que
les énergies renouvelables tels qu'on
les connaît aujourd'hui et dans un
horizon relativement rapproché on
n'arrivera pas à en faire un système
entièrement disponible pilotable avec un
stockage qui permet de remplacer la
production nucléaire qui nous fournit un
socle effectivement qui est constant
dans son annonce il s'agit là existe
mais on a mangé notre pain blanc
c'est l'hydroélectricité sauf qu'ils se
trouvent que l'europe aujourd'hui est
équipée à 90 attaque pas dans 90 % de
son potentiel technique
donc on n'ira pas beaucoup plus loin là
dessus par contre les gros barrages
on peut faire un système totalement
pilotable la norvège en est un exemple
la norvège fait toute son électricité
avec des barrages ça marche très bien le
brésil fait l'essentiel de son
électricité avec des barrages barrage en
france ou alors avec d'autres noms ne
peut plus de dix ans on voit là ils
tombent plus ils tombent pas c'est donc
pour qu'on puisse encore capté beaucoup
d'options vers le solaire l'éolien y
compris l'éolien offshore on dit on peut
construire aujourd'hui des grosses
capacités notamment en offshore à des
coûts qui deviennent de plus en plus
compétitif et qui pourraient nous
fournir une base d'électricité
relativement stable qui ferait qu'on
pourrait dépendre moins de nucléaire ça
c'est pas possible alors je vais vous
donner de chiffres on a déjà mis
au moment où on se parle complètement à
fin 2017 les français ont déjà engagé
120 milliards d'euros pour construire
des éoliennes et des panneaux solaires
au titre de tous les contrats qui ont
été passés avec des producteurs à fin
ce à quoi il faut rajouter les 25
milliards qui ont été promis sur
l'éolien offshore
ça fait 145 milliards avec ses 145
milliards
vous n'allez pas éviter de co2 vous
allez produire quelques pour cent de
l'électricité française à 5 % en ordre
de grandeur
oui oui c'est à peu près ça on s'en est
en ordre de grandeur
c'est aujourd'hui le solaire fait un peu
plus d'un pour cent et l'éolien fait 5%
donc je m'étais moi 6 mais peu importe
et c'est vous n'allez pas éviter de co2
avec ces mêmes 145 milliards vous auriez
pu offrir une pompe à chaleur à chaque
français chauffés au gaz et au fioul
à chaque français à 15 millions de
foyers vous auriez éviter 10 milliards
d'importations par en pétrole et gaz
vous auriez éviter 20% du co2 nationale
et vous auriez créer deux cent mille
emplois dans l'économie nationale
bon là on est en train de s'occuper d'un
faux problème qui est un truc totalement
secondaire en investissant en sommes il
y a et notre temps disponible dans
quelque chose qui est déjà traité depuis
30 ans à une réserve près peut-être
on comprend que vous dites le débat est
trop focalisée sur le nucléaire et du
coup on oublie d'autres d'autres
investissements qui pourraient beaucoup
plus rentable en termes d'émissions de
co2 fait pas il ya un sujet cela dit qui
est le nouveau nucléaire c'est à dire la
construction éventuelle de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires
est-ce qu'on peut les éviter et est-ce
que l'arbitrage en termes de prix est
toujours le même quand on voit le
dérapage des coûts qu'on peut avoir sur
le nouveau nucléaire aujourd'hui alors
tu reçois ce qui éclipse un flat mobile
par exemple
alors il ya beaucoup de questions dans
cette histoire première île 30 secondes
en 30 secondes je répondrais mal donc le
la première chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'en france on n'arrête pas de
s'exciter sur flamanville on oublie de
parler autant de tai shan qui sont les
deux premiers ep air qui vont rentrer en
fonctionnement dans le monde en chine
qui seront terminés pour 5 milliards de
dollars pièce c'est à dire en gros la
moitié du coût de flamanville
tout simplement parce que construit un
réacteur c'est beaucoup de génie civil
c'est des trucs sur lequel les français
ont perdu la main parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'ils sont donc pas fait donc
la première fois qu'ils refont ils
refont un certain nombre de bêtises
pas grave pour la sûreté mais qui vont
coûter de l'argent la deuxième chose
c'est que le nucléaire est un étang une
infrastructure où l'essentiel du coût et
dans la construction
vous êtes le coût du billet water en
sortie dépend énormément de ce qu'on
appelle le coût de l'argent c'est à dire
là les intérêts que vont vous demander
vos actionnaires et vos banquiers pour
vous donner l'argent qui va vous
permettre de construire le réacteur
selon que ses intérêts sont à 2% ou à
10%
même avec un de pêcheurs votre
mégawattheure il sort à 45 300 euros
c'est pas exactement pareil donc il ya
un deuxième sujet sur le nucléaire qui
est d'avoir des modes de financement qui
font que c'est pas vu comme un truc
monstrueusement risqué pour
l'actionnaire et à qui va vous demander
à ce moment des rendements extrêmement
élevé ensuite le nucléaire est un
système complet sire que lui ce pilote
le nucléaire permet de faire avancer le
train de 8 heures du matin à huit heures
du matin
l'éolienne s'il n'y a pas de vent à 8
heures du matin le train de 8 heures du
matin n'avance pas donc comparer les
coûts de sortie d'éoliennes et les coûts
de sortie du nucléaire c'est comparer
des choux et des carottes pour comparer
des choses comparables
il ya que deux manières ou bien vous
comparer le coût du combustible évité
par un moyen que vous devez garder de
toute façon avec le coût complet de
l'énergie renouvelable et à ce moment en
france comme le coût du combustible
éviter dans un réacteur nucléaire c'est
un euro eh bien il faut que l'éolien
descendent à 1 2
le mégawattheure pour qu'il soit
concurrentiel le soler redescendre à 1
euros le mégawattheure pour qu'il soit
concurrentiel
je pense pas qu'on dise fois encore je
pense pas qu'on y sera demain matin à
cela il faut ajouter soit dit en passant
qu'aujourd'hui les panneaux solaires et
les éoliennes c'est une industrie
mondialisée qui dépend des combustibles
fossiles dire que le jour où vous
n'aurez que des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires pour fabriquer
d'autres éoliennes et d'autres panneaux
solaires y compris avec la mine en amont
la métallurgie en amont la chimie en
amont etc
on restera pas à 100 euros le
mégawattheure pour le solaire ça je peux
vous l'assurer donc cette histoire de
comparaisons de coûts est un truc qui
aujourd'hui surf sur un milliard de
malentendus on croit que on peut faire
une bonne affaire parce qu'on compare
pas des systèmes qui sont ronds avec les
mêmes périmètres et parce qu'on oublie
que aujourd'hui si l'éolien et le
solaire coûte pas cher c'est grâce aux
combustibles fossiles
je remercie beaucoup je crois qu'on a
bien compris la complexité du sujet
j'espère que quand on aura les décisions
du gouvernement à la fin du mois on
résumera pas à un ou deux chiffres parce
que ce sera forcément beaucoup plus
complexe que si si ça va se résumer à
deux chiffres merci beaucoup en tout cas
est très bonne journée à vous merci au
revoir
[Musique]